[Musique]
bienvenue dans afrique connecte avec
l'avènement en guinée d'alpha condé au
pouvoir en 2010 on pensait révolues ce
qui était perçu comme une tradition les
coups de forces militaires mais
l'entêtement du dirigeant à se maintenir
au pouvoir fait ressurgir les bruits
baudet militaire avec à leur tête le
colonel mamadou doumbouya ont pris le
pouvoir dans l'attentes d'élections
démocratiques comme au mali ou au tchad
alors pourquoi la guinée reste engluée
dans cette spirale de coup d'état comme
une malédiction on en parle avec notre
invité l'opposant oury bâ fondateur de
l'ufdg le parti de l'un des principaux
leaders de l'opposition guinéenne cellou
dalein diallo il dirige un autre
mouvement lui des rg l'union des
démocrates pour la renaissance de la
guinée bonjour à vous oury bah merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans
l'afrique connect est un plaisir partagé
merci beaucoup alors l'avènement au
pouvoir je le disais d'alpha condé a
suscité beaucoup d'espoir pour la
démocratie dans votre pays des espoirs
déçus si bien que le coup d'état du 5
septembre n'a pas surpris est-ce que
c'était prévisible pour vous également
tu était tout à fait prévisible puisque
comme il foot il faut le rappeler
monsieur alpha condé est parvenu au
pouvoir à la suite d'une transition qui
malheureusement c'était mal conclu est
ce les dix années au pouvoir n'ont pas
permis ne lui ont pas permis peut-être
par mauvaise volonté de mettre en place
une gouvernance credic vertueuse pour
parvenir à faire en sorte que
l'alternance démocratique se substitue
aux éternels coup d'état à la fin de son
second mandat il a cherché par tous les
moyens y compris des moyens tout à fait
inadmissible à se maintenir au pouvoir
en changeant une constitution en
utilisant la force brutale contre les
forces qui s'opposaient à ce troisième
mandat et en fin de compte il est
parvenu à cette fin
mais ça n'a pas duré puisque les germes
de la
de son éviction était déjà en place
monsieur riba depuis l'indépendance
acquise en 1958 l'armée s'érige dans le
jeu politique en arbitre dans le jeu
politique de la guinée résultat le pays
a connu trois coups de force militaire
en plus de nombreuses tentatives réelle
ou présumée on voit cela avec un aléa de
cazaux nous avons décidé de dissoudre la
constitution en vigueur des sources les
institutions
5 septembre 2021 le colonel mamadou
doumbouya et ses hommes annonce la
capture du président guinéen la junte
aubéry rouge quand le pouvoir et met fin
au troisième mandat d'alpha condé un
putsch aux allures de déjà vu pour les
guinéens en 60 ans et le troisième coup
d'état auquel il assiste époque sékou
touré 1958 premier président de la
république de guinée le père de
l'indépendance
né aux états unis ne verra pas de
successeur démocratiquement élue à sa
mort en 84 l'avenir du pays se règle par
un coup d'état mené par le colonel
lansana conté à peine un an après un
autre colonel diarra traoré loupé son
putsch ce qui déclenche une crise de
confiance entre l'état et son armée
résultat vingt militaires sont condamnés
à mort
en 2008 après le décès de lansana conté
le capitaine moussa dadis camara alors
inconnu au bataillon prend la tête du
pays en septembre 2009 des milliers
d'opposants à la candidature de dadis
camara à l'élection présidentielle se
réunissent au stade de conakry l'armée
ouvre le feu à bout portant bilan 157
morts un an plus tard c'est alpha condé
qui accède au pouvoir par les urnes mais
depuis sa réélection contestée en 2021
la dérive autoritaire du président crise
de son pays opposants emprisonnés et
élections truquées
répression des organisations
internationales
augmentation des taxes tout est là pour
générer des tensions entre la population
et son gouvernement après le mali et le
tchad tous deux victimes de coup d'état
cette année la guinée ne fait plus
figure d'exception démocratique dans la
région si alpha condé n'avait pas
attraper la maladie du troisième mandat
la stabilité auraient-elles perdurer en
attendant les guinéens s'en remettent à
leur nouveau président colonel doumbouya
qui a prêté serment le 1er octobre lors
d'une cérémonie boudée par les chefs
d'état de la cedeao
nationale
oui bah on vient de le voir dans ce
sujet de léa descazaux c'est sans doute
le fait marquant de ces années de putsch
en guinée le massacre du 28 septembre
2009 150 morts faut aussi noter des
viols collectifs des violences sexuelles
commis contre des jeunes filles et des
femmes vous étiez vous sur place en tant
que président de la commission
d'organisation de cette manifestation au
stade le 28 septembre 2009 manifestation
on l'a vu réprimées dans le sang soo
l'ex chef de la junte le capitaine dadis
camara un massacre à il faut le préciser
encore impunis cela dit quoi sur la
place et le rôle des militaires en
guinée cyan bon la crise guinéenne
depuis l'indépendance et tout atelier
également aux forces de défense et de
sécurité qui dans une large mesure sont
totalement infondées vous pouvoir en
place
donc les différentes répression qui ont
été organisées par le passé et récemment
ce sont les fêtes des forces de défense
et de sécurité donc l'élément central
qui justifie la domination par eux en
guinée par des régimes autoritaires
c'est le fait que l'armée dans sa
globalité a toujours été légitimiste au
regard des intérêts des pouvoirs en
place si noah dans d'autres contextes ça
ne prenez pas pu prospérer c'est la
seule fois le 5 septembre dernier comme
président en exercice a été déposée par
des forces de défense et de sécurité
c'est la première fois depuis le début
de l'indépendance
c'est vrai qu'on parle souvent de la
faiblesse des armées africaines on le
voit notamment dans le domaine de la
lutte contre le terrorisme et dans même
temps on voit que c'est une armée qui
occupe souvent une place centrale dans
les rouages du pouvoir parce que dans
une large mesure ce sont les forces de
défense et de sécurité qui sont
structurés organisés et en capacité de
prendre le pouvoir lorsqu'il ya une
défaillance du régime en place suite à
un décès suite à une crise majeure les
forces politiques
organisé un thème deux parties n'ont pas
encore la capacité organisationnelle
suffisante surtout dans un pays qui est
marqué par systématiquement par la
violence et donc il ya cette difficulté
de d'agir politiquement dans un contexte
où la violence prendre facilement le
dessus sur tout sur toutes les autres
formes de protestation
la plupart des chefs de jantes que la
guinée a connu que ce soit dadis camara
ou sékouba konaté après lui sont issus
de l'ethnie des forestiers alpha condé
le président déchu lui il et malinkés
cellou dalein diallo son principal rival
éternel rival et paul on dit d'ailleurs
que c'est pour cette raison qu'il ne
peut pas accéder à la magistrature
suprême en guinée est ce que la question
ethnique elle est intimement liée à
cette spirale de coup d'état dans votre
pays
bon les deux se sont à différencier
parce que il ya une réalité qui est
devenu j'allais dire
structurel depuis l'indépendance les
pouvoirs en place ont toujours utilisé
l'ethno stratégie pour confisquer les
attributs de la souveraineté de
l'ensemble du peuple guinéen et donc
ceci est un fait mais en ce qui concerne
disons la composition
ethnique de l'armée c'est la faiblesse
de la gouvernance qui amène dans cette
mesure l'armée à intervenir et
malheureusement les pouvoirs qui se sont
succédé ont toujours développé cette
opposition à toutes les ethnies par
exemple en ce qui concerne ce que vous
venez de dire par rapport
à monsieur cellou dalein diallo dans le
cadre des dix années qui se sont
écoulées il ne faut pas perdre de vue
c'est vrai qu'il y avait eu une
répression ciblée ethniquement du côté
de la communauté peule surtout au niveau
de conakry mais il faut le rappeler est
le souligner la communauté qui a le plus
pâti de la gouvernance de monsieur alpha
condé au point de vue de répression
systématique et ma cible ce sont les
communautés de la guinée forestière où
on ne peut pas dénombrer le nombre de
personnes qui ont été tuées durant les
10 années qui se sont écoulées donc la
question ethnique doit être prise dans
une globalité et toutes les communautés
nationales peuvent ou prou en subissent
les conséquences et c'est la raison pour
laquelle
l'arrivée de du colonel doumbia à la
tête du cnrd est une première dans une
dimension où la question ethnique et le
léguer au second plan parce que monsieur
doumbouya est issu de la même communauté
ethnique que monsieur alpha connue mais
quelle analyse vous faites sur la
manière dont les présidents successifs
guinéen justement ont pu ou pas
instrumentaliser cette question ethnique
à des fins politiques vous savez depuis
très longtemps on est victime de la
crise de l'état l'état guinéen tel qu'il
se présente c'est une prolongation de
l'état colonial mais avec disons des
responsables africains de responsables
guinéens qui ont pris la place du côlon
donc le système néo patrimonial la
volonté de céder le pouvoir pour
confisquer les ressources au service
d'une clientèle soit ethnique soit
familial est l'élément central de la
proportion de ceux et de celles qui sont
en compétition pour le pouvoir politique
jusqu'à présent c'est la raison pour
laquelle dès qu'ils parviennent au
pouvoir il faut maintenir un clan il
faut diviser la population il faut
opposer les uns aux autres pour avoir la
possibilité de tirer profit de siphonner
les ressources publiques pour simplement
entretenir des réseaux clientélistes et
c'est le problème qu'il faut de fonds il
faut remédier à la nature de cet état
changer le fonctionnement met en place
une gouvernance beaucoup plus crédible
qui prend l'ensemble des guinéens comme
des citoyens à part entière c'est
l'enjeu de la situation acuelle oury bah
pourquoi la guinée ne parvient pas à
tourner la page des coups d'état sur
cette question va écouter l'avis de
mamadou aliou barry que vous connaissez
bien un spécialiste des questions de
défense et de sécurité en afrique il
dirige à conakry le centre d'analysés et
d'études stratégiques on n'a pas tiré
les leçons du passé à chaque coup d'état
on ne lit pas comme on dit le plus
souvent le livre de l'histoire de la
guinée si vous souvenez par exemple
rapidement quand même je sais qu'on
pouvait voir à 4,5 les militaires ont
pris le pouvoir ils ont perpétué le
système sans faire aucune analyse pour
essayer de faire un diagnostic afin
d'éviter que remettre en commettre les
mêmes erreurs du passé
je dirais pour vous répondre que
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que c'est
l'éternel recommencement
on n'a pas assez tiré les leçons du
passé affirme mamadou aliou barry qui
est concernée est ce que c'est vous la
place politique est ce que vous vous
sentez responsable quand je dis vous
l'ensemble de l'opposition
bien entendu parce que vous savez que le
site je peux résumer la réalité dans
laquelle
baignant aujourd'hui depuis
l'indépendance jusqu'à présent on était
dans le même cycle politique un état
répressif des élites porté vers la
corruption vers les détournements de
deniers publics
une commune volonté de confisquer les
attributs de l'ensemble de la
souveraineté c'est l'adn de la classe
politique qui a pris la place du collège
jusqu'à présent et nous arrivons à la
limite de ce système néo patrimonial
prédateurs qui fait que depuis deux
années même avec monsieur alpha condé le
pays était dans une crise profonde dans
une crise de mise en pause et l'arrivée
des deux colonels doumbouya et
espérons-le de paix lui tu as le
démarrage sur deux pour un nouveau cycle
qui espérons le sera un titre portera
ainsi l'ouverture mais dans le contexte
actuel comme vous pourrez le constater
nous l'observons quotidiennement il ya
une lutte j'allais dire dialectique
entre l'ancien et le nouveau qui
pour le moment qui l'emportera ce n'est
pas fondamentalement arquois tranché
mais il ya une volonté d'aller de
l'avant avec des forces politiques
beaucoup plus jeunes avec une société
qui s'est ouverte sur les réalités du
monde avec une capacité de communication
extraordinaire que les réseaux sociaux
ont pu impacter je pense que la guinée
dans le contexte actuel avec la nouvelle
transition est peut-être en voie d'aller
dans un seul un autre cycle politique
qui va être une rupture par rapport à
l'ancienne en tout cas c'est l'espoir
que j'ai dans le contexte actuel vous
évoquiez le colonel al mahdi
doumbouya on va s'y attarder tout à
l'heure mais on va marquer une courte
pause et on se retrouve dans un instant
rester avec nous sur rt france
retour dans afrique honnête nous sommes
avec oury bâ l'opposant l'iba président
de l'union des démocrates pour la
renaissance de la guinée on évoque avec
lui cette spirale des coups d'état dans
son pays autre question intéressante
oury bâ l'adhésion des populations
guinéennes au coup de force militaire on
va écouter à nouveau à ce propos mamadou
aliou barry
c'est bien simple clic de façon très
simple c'est que monsieur alpha condé a
été votre humaine d'un coup d'état
constitutionnel parce qu'il a
tripatouillé la constitution surpoids un
troisième mandat et aujourd'hui le débat
se pose au niveau même de la communauté
des états de l'afrique de l'ouest qu'est
ce qu'il ne faut pas aujourd'hui mettre
sur le même sur la même base les coups
d'état concerts et les coups d'état
militaires et la liesse populaire
s'explique pour une rentrée sans la
guinée était dans une crise politique
sur laquelle est venue sa bosse et une
délicate crise économique c'était une
charge de plans qui était sur la tête du
peuple de guinée et le 5 septembre a été
pour le peuple guinéen une vraie
délivrance
pendant dix ans la guinée avec un régime
autoritaire c'est le paradoxe à la tête
de l'état guinéen à l'émission à condé
qui a été présenté comme un opposant
défenseurs de la démocratie
malheureusement il s'est mis très vite
en autocrate et il a instauré dans le
pays pendant dix ans les régimes
autoritaires nom de la population
vilaine a vu au 5 septembre la fin d'un
calvaire c'est pourquoi il aime cette
liesse populaire mais je pense pas que
cette lettre que l'art est un chèque en
blanc le donner aux nouvelles autorités
guinéennes
oury bâ mamadou aliou barry parle de
délivrance pour les populations à ce que
vous faites vous partie de ceux qui
estiment finalement qui félicite les
militaires pour ce coup d'état
bon vous savez on on était dans une
situation vraiment très difficile
monsieur alpha condé aller jusqu à avoir
des attitudes qui ne peut pas se
justifier politiquement humainement
imaginez vous quelqu'un qui bloque le
sel sous les frontières de son pays avec
les pays limitrophes comme la guinée
bissau et le sénégal pendant plus d'un
an dans un contexte de covile 19 ou les
populations sont déjà extrêmement
affaibli et ruiné par disons cette
pandémie vous en rajoutez avec une
situation politique complètement
répressive et puis vous avez là la manie
de fermer les frontières de couper les
liens économiques et les liens
traditionnels qui unissent la guinée est
les pays d'alentour c'est pratiquement
une attitude de suicidaire qui l'a
engagé et donc à l'heure actuelle la
population guinéenne
exprime un grand soulagement mais cela
ne veut pas dire comme l'a dit aliou que
c'est un chèque en blanc donné aux
nouvelles autorités mais
fondamentalement
les gens recommencent à espérer pour
l'avenir ça reste un coup d'état qui a
été saluée par des scènes de liesse
populaire on l'a vu mais c'est vrai
aussi la communauté internationale a
condamné ce coup d'état ce que vous le
comprenez bon la communauté
internationale de ce point de vue
notamment la cedeao et l'union africaine
n'ont pas assumé leurs responsabilités
lorsque les forces démocratiques de la
guinée ont demandé à l'union africaine
et à la cedeao de venir au secours de la
population guinéenne comme vous devez le
savoir et la constitution de 2010
avaient verrouillé le
cette disposition qui devait empêcher
la possibilité pour un président de deux
d'avoir plus de demande à la cedeao à l
union africaine ont fermé les yeux parce
que dans le protocole de gouvernance
concernant les élections la démocratie
et les élections de l'union africaine il
est
spécifiquement indiqué que le fait
d'utiliser des arguments juridiques ou
des changements que vous pour enterrer
la possibilité d'une alternance est un
véritable coup d'état mais ils ont fermé
les yeux et ils ont donné un chèque en
blanc à monsieur alpha condé la cdo de
même a été
à fait preuve de complicité passive et
c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui lorsqu'il y a eu ce qu'on
peut appeler une rectification
institutionnel la cedeao et l'union
africaine n'ont pas suffisamment de
crédits pour imposer leur loi et le
déshydrateur mais bon il faut qu'on
tienne compte de la réalité
de ces organisations supranationales
mais fondamentalement elles n'ont pas
été à la hauteur de l'attenté de la
population guinéenne c'est pour cela
aujourd'hui les recommandations son lit
parfois avec un peu de comme si ils
étaient là uniquement comme en scène des
cas de chefs d'état alors vous partager
le sentiment d'aller au bar il faut pas
donner de chèque en blanc justement ou
militaires et pour autant vous semblez
fondé beaucoup d'espoir en la personne
de mamadou doumbouya pour quelles
raisons bon je pense qu il est issu
d'une nouvelle génération
en tant que militaire il n'est pas du
sérail il a fait ses débuts dans les
forces de défense et de sécurité dans la
légion française
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est en d'euros
dans une certaine mesure de ceux qui
prévalent et raffiné et là aussi ça
c'est sa vie privée mais je ne pouvais
son épouse et une française donc c'est
quelqu'un qui de ce point de vue se
démarque disons d'une attitude
suffisamment conformiste par rapport à
la réalité de notre pays dans ce sont
des atouts qui montre qu'il a une
capacité de la vie de manière autonome
de manière indépendante
en tant que citoyen et je pense que ce
soit ont des prédispositions utile pour
un leadership d'aller dans le bon sens
de mettre tout le monde au même pied
d'égalité et d'agir en conformité avec
les intérêts majeurs de la population
guinéenne est de l'intérêt de mettre en
place un système politique que faire
perdurer la démocratie et les
possibilités d'alternance sans tenir
compte des intérêts de clan ou des
intérêts et nick aurait là je vous
propose d'écouter mahmoud si l'instinct
activistes pro alpha condé opposés au
coup d'état en guinée mais sur tout le
continent ils ne parlent pas lui de coup
d'état mais de kidnapping et d'ingérence
étrangère
seule coupe de france ça n'a rien à voir
avec l'armée qui n'aide je vais être
sincère envers vous je condamne le coup
d'état parce que celui qui a fait sur
coup d'état n'a rien à voir avec l'armée
guinéenne c'est une force spéciale créée
dans le but de s'assurer d'assurer la
sécurité du président de la république
est de lutter contre les rebelles donc
ce monsieur a profité de sa position
actuelle avec le président de la
république parce que ça n'allait pas du
tout entre lui est là et le gouvernement
qui n'est donc il a profité de cela pour
kidnapper le président de la retenue
dans le but de sauver sa peau ou
condamant que ce coup d'état c'est parce
que le président de la république le pr
alpha condé a diversifié
l'investissement à robbie keane et tous
les autres pays ont eu leur place en
plus de guinée on lui fait même de
reproches de donner la guinée à la chine
oury bâ votre réaction aux propos tenus
par mahmoud s'il a d'abord sur
l'hypothèse d'un règlement de comptes
entre le colonel mamadou doumbouya et
alpha condé puis l'ingérence étrangère
on a plus d informations sur la manière
dont les choses se sont passées avant le
5 septembre le colonel doumbia était en
en insécurité en république de guinée sa
sécurité était en danger puisque
certaines forces politiques notamment
l'ancien ministre de la défense et
ministre des affaires présidentielles
monsieur gagny de sources bien informées
était en train de vouloir
détruire les forces spéciales et pour
faire émerger une autre unité d'élite
qui serait totalement à sa dévotion et
c'était une course contre la montre
monsieur gagné
avec une santé fragile de monsieur alpha
condé depuis qu'il est était allé en
turquie pour le faire sa visite médicale
le pronostic d'après satin était vital
était engagé donc le clan a voulu se
maintenir en déposant le président alpha
condé mais il fallait éliminer les
forces susceptibles d'entraver ce
processus notamment les forces spéciales
celles ci étant mise au courant on
réagit le plus vite et on déposait aussi
bien monsieur alpha condé le bas sur
l'ingérence étrangère vous êtes d'accord
ou pas d'accord non je ne suis pas
d'accord c'est toujours cette manie de
présenter tout ce qui arrive en guinée
comme le fait de l'étranger comme si en
guinée les gens n'ont aucune
responsabilité sur le sort de leur pays
monsieur alpha condé a été responsable
de la situation de dégradation de la
situation économique politique et
financière de la guinée il a deux malgré
tout les liens qui l'unissaient à la
france
plus précisément il n'a pas voulu aller
dans une dynamique de maintien des
fondamentaux démocratiques ça lui a
aliéné aussi bien ses amitiés de
certains chefs d'état africains comme le
président issoufou que ses amitiés
personnelles qui sont nombreuses un peu
par tout le monde aurait pas pour
conclure pour conclure rapidement il ya
beaucoup de coup d'état une vague de
coups d'état sur le continent africain
en afrique de l'ouest un la guinée le
mali
en afrique de l'est le soudan et des
tentatives aussi un des jouets notamment
en guinée-bissau ce que ça vous inquiète
cette spirale bonjour je pense que les
sociétés africaines sont en mouvement là
les états tels qu'ils existent sont
profondément en crise et la recherche
d'un point d'équilibré amène des
soubresauts et nous sommes dans une
période historique qui est assimilable à
la période historique que l'amérique
latine a reconnu il ya vingt ans de cela
avec des coups d'état systématique mais
les sociétés étaient à la recherche des
positions déquilibre pour mettre en
place d'une gouvernance plus ou moins
démocratique je pense que le continent
africain avec plus de drames avec tous
de tragédie est en train d'aller dans
cette direction et il nous appartient
en ce qui concerne la guinée de monter
qu'il y a à travers cette crise une
possibilité d'une sortie par le haut
pour l'intérêt de la guinée pour
l'intérêt de la région et que ça puisse
être un point de repère pour redonner de
l'espoir en ce qui concerne le renouveau
démocratique chez le continent merci
beaucoup à vous autorise bas d'avoir
participé à cette émission
est moins cupide merci retrouver après
connexion aux réseaux sociaux et en
replay sur notre site rtl france pointe
et merci aux équipes du mag et
techniques pour la préparation de cette
émission merci de votre attention à très
bientôt dans après connecte sur arte
france
[Musique]